عندها بدأت في البكاء عندما
وصلت إلى تلك الجملة، كان الأمر كما لو كان واو
العيفي ولينا آر يقولان إنه لا يزال من الصعب
قراءة ما مرت به ابنتهما البالغة من العمر 13 عامًا، عندما
تقرأه وتشعر
وكأنك تشاهد فيلم رعب
واحدًا.  التي تكشفت في قاعات
مدرسة متوسطة في جورجيا الوسطى
قبل شهر واحد، تم القبض على مدرس الدراسات الاجتماعية بنيامين ريس البالغ من العمر 51 عامًا
بزعم تهديده بقطع رأس
ابنتهما وذبحها بعد أن
أخبرته أنها وجدت عرضًا
للعلم الإسرائيلي.  في هجوم الفصل الدراسي،
تم إدراج أكثر من 20 شاهدًا في
تقرير مطول عن حادثة شريف، حيث
روى الكبار رؤية ريس تتبع
ثلاث فتيات صغيرات في القاعة وهم يصرخون
بتهديدات عنيفة وكأنها
أم غبية وسأسحبها من الجزء
الخلفي من سيارتي و  قطع رأسها بسبب
عدم احترام العلم اليهودي،
اتُهم ريس بجعل
التهديدات الإرهابية جناية وقسوة على الأطفال
من الدرجة الثالثة، وتم إطلاق سراحه
بكفالة قدرها 7500 دولار كأب، شعرت أن
ابنتي ليست آمنة ولا أعرف
ذلك  إنها ليست آمنة ولا أستطيع حتى
حمايتها، مرحبًا، قمنا بزيارة ريس في المنزل
لكنه رفض التعليق قائلًا إن
محاميه سيتواصل حتى الآن وهذا
لم يحدث ولا تظهر سجلات المحكمة أن
المحامي المدرج في
مدارس مقاطعة ريس هون أخبر CNN أن ريس هي  لم
تعد موظفة في المنطقة وهو
شيء تقول ALU إنها تقدره لكنها لا
تزال تخشى على
سلامة ابنتها، لديك دائمًا هذا ماذا لو
استمرت هذه التهديدات التي تعرفها
وظهرت في منزلي كما
يقول أمريكي فلسطيني ALU الحرب في
لم تشعر غزة أبدًا بأنها بعيدة عن
أسرهم، لكنهم لم يتوقعوا أن
يصل إليهم التأثير المضاعف في
مجتمع وارنر روبينز المحبوب،
مجتمع صغير محب، ليس لدينا أي
مشكلة على الإطلاق، كما تعلمون أي مشكلة ولكن
المدافعين عن الحقوق المدنية يقولون ما حدث
لابنتهم  في حين أن التطرف يتناسب مع
النمط الذي ظهر في جورجيا والذي
يعكس اتجاهًا وطنيًا مع ارتفاع كبير
في التقارير المعادية للسامية والمعادية للمسلمين
والعرب في الأشهر التي
أعقبت هجوم حماس في 7 أكتوبر
ووسط الحصار الإسرائيلي المستمر
للجيب، فقد ارتفعت الأرقام بشكل كبير
في  دولة الخوخ عند مقارنة
الأشهر الثلاثة من 2022 إلى 2023
تكون الزيادات 1100
لكل.  هذا أمر مذهل، إنه أمر صادم أننا
لم نكن أكثر انشغالًا من قبل في هذه الأثناء، جامعة ولاية أريزونا
وaifi مشغولان بمحاولة إبقاء الأمور
طبيعية في المنزل أثناء العمل على
ضمان ألا يشكل هذا تهديدًا طويل المدى لقيمة
طفلهما الذاتية، أردتها أن
تكون واثقة من أنها تحب من  إنها
تدافع عن الأشياء الصحيحة ولكي
لا تدع هذا يغيرها الآن،
أخبرتني العائلة أنهم شعروا
بدعم لا يصدق من مجتمعهم
والمدرسة لكنهم يطالبون
المنطقة بتغيير سياسة الإخطار الخاصة بها
بشأن الحوادث الخطيرة التي تشمل
موظفين مثل  يقول المعلمون إن
ابنتهم لم تسمع بعضًا من
التهديدات الأكثر عنفًا لأنها كانت
تحاول الهرب، وعلمت الأسرة بها لأول مرة
ليس من
المنطقة التعليمية ولكن من وسائل الإعلام، والآن عادت
ابنتهم إلى الفصل، ويقولون
ذلك  بذل مدير المدرسة ومسؤول
موارد المدرسة كل ما في وسعهم
للتأكد من شعورها بالأمان، وقاموا بتغيير
الأقفال وهم يراقبونها أيضًا
ولكن ليس عن كثب حتى لا
تشعر بأنها مستهدفة